what's up guys
bang bang it's lunch money time well
wall street's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get our lunch
money right
i'm here with the beautiful intelligent
pauline ivalova marinova pompliano
p-i-m-p
i don't understand why she has a solid
colored
sleeve and a not solid colored dress but
we'll get to that in a second fashion
fashion fashion are you fashionable
yes um well lunch oh sorry go ahead
no go ahead why don't you do the
sponsorship today no no no come on let's
go who's the sponsor all right
we got block fight oh we got block fire
up in the house 8.6
apy 8.6 api 8.6 percent apy
we be cranking we be going i don't know
why you're
uh using uh not proper english
but uh 8.6 apy on an interest-bearing
account
right that you can deposit right or
crypto or stable coin and get up to
eight point six percent apy
oh obviously do they have a crypto
exchange they do they do
yeah is it a good one it's a it's a okay
one it's an okay one it's a good this is
the best one it's the best one oh nice
okay
all right and then what else could have
been a hostage video um
so crypto so they have an interest
bearing account
yeah they have uh crypto exchange crypto
exchange what's the last thing
oh hold on give me the first letter
alone
alone bearing no alone
against against crypto
crypto collateral collateral very good
job
very good job please go help out blockfi
obviously they need a lot of help go to
blockfy.com
lunch money and go check it out today
all right what's up with the news all
right well great news for lunch money
viewers the sec wants to help us get our
lunch money right
why all right the sec you're very
excited about this i like this
sec modernized to modernize today
the accredited investor definition so
kind of so it adopted amendments to the
accredited
investor definition so historically
individual investors who do not meet
specific
income or net worth tests uh regardless
of their financial sophistication have
been denied the opportunity to invest
in and vast private markets
so the amendments update long story
short
is that uh they used to only count you
as an accredited investor
if you if you had a million dollar net
worth or you made 200 000
a year basically that's over generalized
but that's basically what it was
so what they did is they used your net
worth as a proxy for your
ability to invest your intelligence well
as we all know there's a lot of
dumb rich people out there dumb money
stupid money
and also what they used to say is oh
we're trying to protect you from you
right is you need to be smart so rich
people can withstand any sort of dumb
mistake that they make
because they're rich the problem is that
there was no limitation so you could go
put 100 of your net worth
into an investment so you're not really
protecting anybody yeah and so now what
they're going to do is they're
definitely moving in the right direction
the sec should
absolutely be uh kind of pat on the back
good job
you've been talking about this for years
yes they should make a test
an education test that you can literally
go online like the sat
take a test if you can prove that you
understand markets if you can prove that
you understand
how to invest you should be allowed to
invest in any asset that you want
the whole idea is we should not base a
system on net worth we should base it on
education
they're moving in that direction so if
you manage money professionally
if you have a series 6 7 65 whatever the
numbers are
like certain things now are going to
open it up the next step is we got to
get to the point where anyone at home
can log on to a website take a test if
you pass the test you can do it
everything and here's my thing like
there's a lot of immigrants who come
from countries where they you know they
may have been wealthy they may have been
very financially sophisticated but they
come here
they don't have a ton of money but they
still want to invest
how do you do that you can't if you
don't meet these requirements but
i think a tux would make sense agreed
sec good job
keep going ooh sam zell let's go
my guy real estate mogul sam zell has
been very vocal
he calls retail a falling knife that
hasn't hit
a bottom yet bang bang you know what a
falling knife is
no so there's a saying it's like no
don't catch a falling knife
because when a knife is falling you
tried to grab it and if you grab it you
can cut your hand
right i didn't know that but that i mean
i didn't know that so don't catch a
falling knife
basically means what you don't want to
do is if a market goes down 20
and it's really on its way to go down 50
if you buy it at 20 percent
then all it did was it dropped more you
lost money right you just caught the
falling knife
uh so what he's basically saying is by
saying it's a falling knife he believes
that
uh retail real estate uh is going to go
lower and lower he said the pandemic has
accelerated the amount of online retail
and i don't think that's ever going to
change that's going to require future
retail real estate to be
very different than it has been up until
now we walk up and down madison
and park and then you see like these you
know gucci stores
ain't nobody in there nobody's going in
it's over
see you then now look i don't think that
retail real estate is going to go away
forever
i just think it'll look very different
in the future what do you think the
who do you think is going to move into
those spaces i have two predictions
one is we're gonna see the rise of many
malls
i'm calling it here first i've not heard
anyone else talk about it like a mini
horse
no a mini mall is basically they're
gonna take one of those retail places
and they're gonna give uh each type
of luxury brand a single like stand
almost
right and so like you walk into what now
is the gucci store but instead of being
the gucci stores
like the luxury brand store and gucci
will have its little place
you know whatever the next brand i don't
even know what these brands are called
yeah but whatever
it's like a mall but rather than
everyone have their own stores it'll
just be all of it in one store
but isn't that going to be kind of chaos
like i want to look through everything
how we're going to
how are they going to have the space for
all their inventory well
don't you look through everything when
you walk in the gucci stores the same
amount of space same amount of products
it's just now rather than to be 100
gucci it may be 10 gucci 10
products 10 whatever i don't get their
full inventory
situation i only get like a small sample
well people aren't going anyways so
they're not getting it anyways that's
right all right what's next
by the way sam zell is an absolute
legend he loves sam you should go
google samsung if you don't know his
story i have sad news for you
i called it i told i told y'all they
were going to do this american airlines
is i told you all they were about to do
this well they're doing fine they were
going to do something
19 000 jobs in october without aid and
the workforce is shrinking by 30 percent
um 19 000 involuntary cuts oh yeah you
were right you said october didn't you
as the covid 19 pandemic continues to
weigh on air travel
unless the government extends aid for
airline employee payrolls you know how i
knew it was going to be in october
because the ppp money is running out at
the end of september
they have to keep people on the payroll
until the end of september to make sure
that they don't have to pay the money
back
so again like charlie munger always says
you show me the incentives and i'll show
you the outcome
and this is a perfect example the
incentives were for them to hold on to
as many jobs as they could until october
and they were going to fire everybody
30 of their staff they're going to get
rid of
so either they extend it with more
employee benefits or there's going to be
a bunch of job loss
now people can argue what's good what's
not but like that was it was so obvious
that this was going to happen because
that's what the incentives
drove them to do some people would argue
that actually by having it there
we saved people's jobs up until the end
of september
other people would argue that we should
have never done it i'll let you guys all
debate that
but the key is this isn't just an
american airlines thing
american islands best airline americans
but others are doing it as well
americans planned job cuts comprise 17
500 furloughs of union workers including
600
pilots and 8 100 flight attendants in
another 1500 management positions
love it all right what's next i love it
i do not love it
next no love it love it in terms of they
already know exactly like
this is like a pre-planned they know to
the person
who's getting cut who's not who's
involuntary who's not like this isn't
like a
oh we're in trouble we just need to fire
people like no this is
god i really love my sleeve
all right what's happening
[Laughter]
so facebook i don't quite understand
this so i'm going to need you to help it
kind of look
it kind of looks like you blend into the
chair it kind of does doesn't it yeah
there
you go facebook on wednesday
acknowledged that apple's upcoming ios
14 could lead to a more than
50 percent drop in its audience network
advertising business i try to understand
this before we came on here but i really
couldn't
facebook had previously warned that ios
14 could impact its advertising
business but the company's blog posts on
wednesday outline just how specifically
that impact could be so the whole idea
here is
you probably don't know what audience
network no i don't know so audience
network
is a way for uh it's a marketplace
basically
for uh if you're an advertiser and you
want to advertise
facebook has a network of places where
you can do mobile advertising yeah so it
relies on uh the carriers the software
providers all the stuff
to get information for targeting right
so we
we know this may severely impact
publishers ability to monetize through
audience network on ios 14 and despite
our best efforts
may render audience networks so
ineffective on ios 14
that it may not make sense to offer it
on ios 14 in the future
while it's difficult to quantify the
impact of publishers and developers at
this point with so many unknowns
in testing we've seen more than a 50
percent drop in their publisher revenue
when personalization was removed from
mobile
so why why is this happening what's
going on with ios 14.
they're trying to be more privacy
centric so that now
people like facebook and others can't
get more personalized data and so it
takes away the ad target so
so right now advertisers can use a
unique device id number called the idfa
to better target ads and estimate their
effectiveness
but with ios 14 each app that wants to
use this identifiers will ask users to
opt into tracking when the app is first
launched yeah it's a facebook so they
don't want to do that
yep all right next all right winter is
coming no we don't know how
big the revenue from that program is
narrator it's really big oh it's big so
they're just willing to give that all up
of course all right guys winter is
coming
i just said that oh really i literally
did not hear that that's crazy
um okay yeah it's crazy that you don't
listen to me absolutely crazy
go ahead i've always wanted honestly we
should we should have just like a
reality tv show on youtube so that
everything i say can be documented and
then i'll be like do you remember when i
said that and then you'll
okay so i am reality
go ahead you know what sure i want to
say no come on let's go what's going on
selling sunset oh my god for months
restrictions on
indoor dining have forced restaurants
across the country to rely on outdoor
dining to survive but now as the weather
gets colder as it starts to snow
and sleet and ice and wait islito
yes
that lifeline is going away and
uh restaurant operators are scrambling
to figure out what to do next
everybody is scared of winter right now
said the ceo of a new york bus
based restaurant consulting company i
have no clue how restaurants i have no
idea
i have no idea how they're still around
yeah i i i like they're
needing money they're just bleeding cash
and and because they're turned on
they're actually uh losing more money so
not only do they have to pay their rent
but then they also have to pay their
staff their food costs all this kind of
stuff
i have no clue but some degree they just
got to get to work and they're doing the
best they can delivery curbside pickup
outdoor seating all that kind of stuff
in areas where indoor
dining has been banned outright like new
york city and new jersey officials still
haven't laid out a clear path for its
return
bill de blasio said during a press
conference last week that the city would
have to see more improvement
in combating the coronavirus before
considering the option i'm pretty sure
i'm pretty sure you can consider it now
yeah of course
it's all right wow this is really sad
i'm trying to keep all of my thoughts on
the coronavirus but i just don't
understand what's gonna
happen to restaurants well i mean
they're not all gonna disappear but some
of them will oh man
all right what's going on with this
nonsense okay guys so
i'm not sure this is the third place
i've seen this now at first i thought it
was a joke but i don't think it's a joke
there is a new male swimsuit called the
brokini
where it's very hard to describe so
hopefully joe can insert a photo here
it literally there's a strap that goes
like this across your chest and then
like
basically a speedo it's all connected
it's very confusing what is the point of
having the strap
is it a fat fashon staple i think it's a
fashion but also
like to keep things up like we don't
need not sliding down
um but you know how their underwear stay
up just get the right size well it's
just
very very unsettling so
should i get one no um
leave a comment and let me know what i
what uh you would do for me to get a
brokini
oh my god please guys don't
take pictures let's go okay what's going
on two dudes named taylor field and chad
sasco have debuted this product
shocking taylor and chad taylor and chad
so the chads
no god uh so what so i don't really
understand the point of it
uh well obviously it's to make money
that's what this is
this is called a marketing campaign you
create a viral product
like a brokini it becomes a joke and a
meme you get a bunch of press coverage
like
the esquire article that you're reading
right now and then people say oh i
should buy this it would be funny for me
to wear it
and then there's a bunch of people who
go and they actually
buy this wow and they show up to parties
where
our friend dustin said he saw one he saw
a guy wearing one it was lime juice
40 bucks yeah it's a perfect price great
product
very viral getting tons of press
coverage this is a hit right
rokini is going to make a ton of money
brokini i'm not going to get one but
it's going to make money broken
brokini a haiku a bikini for bros show
off your package and style
disappoint parents show off your pants
oh my god this is terrible
all right it's the children's show so
time for a joke
and this joke comes from a very nice
lunch money viewer named adam who felt
bad for me
that i was running out of jokes so he
sent me a website
with all the jokes ready
i always knock on the fridge before
opening it
you know why
why just in case there's a salad
dressing
that one's pretty good see thank you
adam that might be that might be the
first one that i cracked the grin
you cracked your girl i'm gonna make you
laugh like a boisterous laugh
all right i gotta go because i have
stuff in the oven over there yeah so
i'll see you all right guys thanks guys
that's it for lunch money i guess it's
over
uh see you tomorrow bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends